على كل المزيد ينضم الينا بشرم الشيخ
مراسل صباح العربيه احمد عثمان احمد يسعد
صباحك اهلا بك من مصر الحبيبه احمد عندما
نتحدث اليوم عن الملاح نتحدث عن زياده
انبعاثات كربونيه اتحدث عن ازمه الطاقه
قبل حلول فصل الشتاء ونتحدث عن اتساع فجوه
التمويل مصر اليوم تعد بتحويل كل الوعود
في القمم السابقه حول المناخ الى تنفيذ
باجراءات ملموسات ما الذي ينتظره العالم
من قمه شرم الشيخ 27
صباح الخير
اليوم الى شرم الشيخ خلال اليومين
المقبلين وصولا الى يوم 18 نهايه هذا
المؤتمر والتوصيات التي ستخرج به ربما
الحضور القوي من قبل الرؤساء والزعماء الى
شرم الشيخ والذي يعني بدا بالفعل المتوقع
ان يطرده اليوم من قاده من اوروبا واسيا
وافريقيا والعالم العربي يؤكد على ما تم
على ما طرحته سهام من اهميه هذا المؤتمر
والربما ما تم احرازه من خلال ادراج بعض
النقاط المهمه اول جداريه من خلال جدول
الاعمال وربما الرئيسيه في ما يتعلق بنقطه
التمويل هذه النقطه التي كانت تتعلق به
ضروره ان يكون هناك تمويل وصلت يعني
تقيماته الى 100 مليار دولار سنويا ان
يكون على جدول الاعمال والتجاوز كل
الحساسيات والخلافات من كونه عليه تعويضات
ام طويل كل هذه الامور التي كانت صغيره
وعائقه همم تم تجاوزها وهناك ربما نضرب من
التفاؤل فيما يتعلق بامكانيه الانتقال من
حيز العناوين العريضه التي تاتي في
المؤتمرات الى الوصول الى حيز التنفيذ
الفعلي على الارض كل هذه النقاط سيتم
استعراضها خلال الايام اليوم وغدا سيكون
هناك كلمات للقاده يوم الرئيس يصل الى شرم
الشيخ يوم الجمعه في زياره تستغرق ست
ساعات سيرقي كلمته وايضا سيكون هناك خلال
هذه الايام ربما العديد من المشاورات
واللقاءات الثنائيه التي تجمع القاده او
بعض ايضا مع المختصين والمحللين له
الانتقال فعليا سيكون هناك ايضا استعراض
الكثير من ما تم طرحه على ارض الواقع خلال
الفتره الماضيه هناك جناح لي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه سيكون هناك استعراض لما
تم تحقيقه منذ الاعلان عن مبادره الشرق
الاوسط الكبير والشرق الاول السعوديه
الخضراء اا في نهايه العام الماضي سيتم
طرح ايضا ما تم تحقيقه في السعوديه فيما
يتعلق بالانتقال الى عالم اكثر خضره واقل
اضرار بيئيه كل هذه الامور في شرم الشيخ
ستكون شاهده عليها خلال الايام المقبله في
ظل ربما نوع نبرا من التفاؤل هناك ايضا
يعني استمرار لبعض الخلافات كان هناك
احباط حول الاجماع بان فكره الوصول الى
واحد في المئه ونصف انبعثات حراريه يعني
يبقى شبه مستحيل ولكن هناك ايضا جهود
للتواصل لعمليات اخرى تقلل من عمليات
الاضرار المناخيه وتاثيراتها السلبيه
خصوصا على الدول الناميه وتحديدا القاره
الافريقيه طيب مصر سعاد اليوم بخطه انقاذ
بصحيح العباره احمد هل انت تفاصيل او ف-
حول خطه المصريه لانقاذه هنا
نعم يعني هذه الخطه ربما تبدو ملامحها
مبدئيا فيما يتعلق بتحقيق فكره الانتقال
الى عمليه التمويل الى حيز الفعل وليس حيز
الشعارات هذه هي النقطه التي كانت عالقه
هذه النقطه التي كانت تنادي بها الكثير من
الدول الناميه خلال السنوات الاعوام
الماضيه كان هناك ربما رؤيه مشتركه من هذه
الدول بان هذا العنوان البراق يبقى مجرد
نقطه قائده للتفاوض ما بين الدول الغنيه
ما بين دول الاقتصاد الاقتصاديات الكبيره
او الصناعات الصناعات المهمه تحديدا في
الغرب وتحقيقه فعليا من خلال الانتقال الى
مساعدات فعليه الى هذه الدول كيف سيت-
ستكون هذه المساعدات الى الدول الناميه
لتجاوز فيما تجاوز تعثيراتها في ما يتعلق
بالاضرار البيئيه هذه النقاط ربما يبقى
التفاصيل ولكن في حد ذاته ان يكون هناك
على جدول الاعمال اتفاق مبداي او اتفاق من
حيث المبدا على مبدا ليس التعويضات لانها
كلمه التعويضات ربما تثير حساسيات ولكن
مبدا التمويل الفعلي من الدول الغنيه عبر
الامم المتحده الى الدول الفقيره او الدول
الناميه لتجاوز الاضرار البيئيه هذا
العنوان في حد ذاته كان مبهجا للكثيرين
وكان محل فرحه حيث انه تم الانتقال اخيرا
كانت هذه النقطه ربما يتم تجاوزها يتم
تاجيلها ولكن منذ انطلاق قمه باريس ولكن
الان يبدو الوضع مختلفا ويعكس نبرا من
التفاؤل بانه ربما الامور الاخرى الفنيه
قد تحل تدريجيا مع وجود هذا البند او
تحقيق هذا البنك
تعزيز الدولي لمواجهه التغير المناخ شكرا
جزيلا من شرم الشيخ احمد
[موسيقى]